Speaker 1: Many of you have been asking the
question what the hell happened to the Republican
Party? It can be difficult to notice changes
sometimes when those changes happen slowly.
Let's take a look at how the Republican Party has
changed over a longer period of time and then talk
about exactly how it happened. I am going to play
a clip for you here of William F Buckley talking
with Noam Chomsky in 1969. Now, when you do a
progressive show, there is no conservative that
you can put up as an example that you're your
left wing audience. In this case, my left wing
audience will agree. Yeah, this is an example of
sort of like normal conservatism. We disagree with
conservatism. I understand that. Now, I know many
of you will say David Buckley's a loser. He was a
pompous, condescending clown. Okay. Buckley had
a set of principles. He argued them what I would
consider by today's standards. Respectfully, he
stood for something. He engaged with people with
whom he disagreed. Check this out. This was
one flavor of conservatism in the Republican
Party in the late sixties, and it lasted into
the seventies, into the early eighties. Here's
William F Buckley talking with Noam Chomsky.
Speaker 3: Quite so. But you also say that
you hate yourself for not having
come to that position earlier. Yeah,
I do. I think it's a very great, great step. What
I hope to give you a little solace and of. But
the reason I do raise this and I rejoice in
your disposition to argue the Vietnam question,
especially when I recognize what an act of
self-control this must involve. It does. It
really does. I mean, I think this is the kind
of issue where sometimes I lose my temper here,
maybe not tonight, because I view it as
fashion that the into. The thing you say,
you say in your reason for not losing, you say
the war is simply an obscenity, a depraved act
by weak and miserable men, including all of
us, including myself. Well, that's the next
sentence. Same sentence. Sure, sure, sure, sure.
Because you count everybody in the company of the
guilty. I think that's true in part, yeah.
But one of the points obviously sensitive.
Speaker 1: So anyway, these are really interesting
debates and conversations that was like what the
Republican Party one part of it. Right. We can
find wacky examples as well. But you could talk
to these people. Okay. These did they operated
in something that approached reality. Here are
some examples of the modern Republican Party.
Speaker 4: Not only do we have the DC jail, which
is the DC gulag, but now we have Nancy Pelosi's
gazpacho police spying on members of Congress,
spying on the legislative work that we do.
Speaker 1: Gazpacho, police. That's Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor GREENE. Here is another
example of the modern Republican Party.
Speaker 4: But about Ted Cruz lately in
the news. And contrary to popular belief,
I've never been an escort
for Senator Ted Cruz. Hmm.
But I will tell you tonight, it is the coolest
thing I've ever heard of. Yeah. Oh, Ted Cruz.
Speaker 1: There you go. That's a radical
Republican Congresswoman Lauren Boebert. And
then, of course, the modern Republican Party.
Speaker 5: Numerous categories were lower than
the world, lower than lower than in Europe.
Speaker 6: In what? In want. Take a look
right here.
Speaker 5: Here's case death.
Speaker 6: Oh, you're doing death as a proportion
of cases. I'm talking about death as a proportion
of population. That's where the US is really bad.
Well, much worse than South Korea, Germany, etc..
Speaker 5: And you can't do that. You have got to
do. You have to go by. You have to go by where?
Look, here is the United States. You have to go
by the cases, the case. Why not? As a proportion
of population, somebody. What it says is when you
have somebody that has it, where there's a case.
Oh, okay. The people that live from those cases.
Speaker 1: All right. That's a major contrast.
Okay. Point I think point made. Now, you could
say, well, but you know, the modern Republican
Party also has people like Mitt Romney in it.
Yeah. How much attention do they get? They have
been pushed to the fringes. So how did this
happen? And this is the story that I've told
before. In fact, when when I interviewed Noam
Chomsky, we talked about this story. Whatever you
think about Noam Chomsky, I'm just saying there's
a discussion about the story in that interview,
and the path is more or less as follows from the
William F Buckley clip to what I just played for
you from from the Orange Menace, the civil rights
era. Set off a period of extreme instability in
the American right, where many in the American
right did not like what the civil rights era
brought. When they talk about their worldview.
We say it sort of sounds like they want to go
back to the 1950s. That's exactly right. Before
the civil rights era, which started, you know,
you could argue 58 or different people
would put it at a different point that.
And the attempt to level the playing field in
many ways started to anger much of the right
where not really metabolically, but others
started to get away from what we might now
called that principled conservatism of of
a certain point. Through the Vietnam War
and into the Reagan era. We saw this shift into
what we might call more kind of like meme politics
from the right actor. Ronald Reagan comes up with
stuff like, you know, the Cadillac driving welfare
mom and and starting to make these caricatures
of people hanging out, living richly on welfare
and on and on. Although Reagan was still sort
of reasonable compared to the modern Republican
Party on something like immigration, but that
was just one step. We then go from Reagan and
I'm condensing the story to Bill Clinton, knocking
out one term, making George H.W. Bush a one term
president, which in 1992 significantly angered
many in the Republican Party. To then Newt
Gingrich becoming Speaker of the House in 1994, in
the 1994 midterms. That was the next escalation.
It's not even really an escalation. It's like if
you have. Rhetoric on one side and policy on the
other. It continued the shift of the Republican
Party from policy to rhetoric. Newt Gingrich in
1994 starting to develop the more cartoonish
social conservative, starting to get a little
bit more detached from policy. Then when you had
the Clinton Lewinsky scandal, it escalated what we
could probably call Clinton derangement syndrome,
Kenneth Starr's investigation, etc.. And then it
set the stage for the first what I would call
the modern kind of like dumb Republican. George
W Bush. Now, George W Bush, I'm sure personally,
he's a nice guy. And in some of the he has been
more thoughtful in some of the statements he's
made publicly since leaving office, particularly
over the last 5 to 6 years. But George W
Bush, with his made up words and confusion
about foreign policy and all these things,
ushered in the first kind of like, you know.
Lightweight, intellectually lightweight. In the
more modern way movement in the Republican Party,
then Barack Obama won and it just unleashed an E.
But you took the Bush contingent or constituency
and added some overt racism, and that was the next
escalation. And then, of course, then ultimately
we got to Trump. That's the path. That's the
40, 50 year path. And it's really important to
understand it when we think about how we got from
William F Buckley to Donald Trump. Right, the guy
who's staring at a solar eclipse and saying,
what about injecting bleach? It's a sad decline
and it's unclear where the Republican Party goes
next, but it's good to know how we got here.